hey it's me again in this video we're
going to talk about flabby skin whether
it's in the back of your arms and
underneath your chin or your legs your butt
or your hips let's cover what's
underneath that now in the past video
I've talked about cortisol which is an
adrenal hormone being the root cause of
loose skin and if you're on but there's
another very common cause and that has
to do with this one hormone called
insulin okay but it's really a condition
of insulin resistance but let me just
explain what that means insulin
resistance is a condition where you have
a ton of insulin but it's not working
okay because your body is resisting at
the cellular level all right now you
need insulin you definitely you
cannot live without it but the problem
is we have too much of it because there
are diets like sugars and things like
that
but check this out your cells have a
little window that allows insulin to
drive fuel in the cells but also insulin
is one of the main hormones that drives
amino acid into the cells it's the
hormone that allows the absorption of
proteins specifically branched amino
acids now what does branched amino acids
now you see this a lot of times and
people that are exercising weightlifters
because branched amino acids are
specifically good to repair and
replenish lost muscle okay so if you're
losing muscle you atrophying you would
want branch amino acids but the problem
is the insulin is not working to pull
those amino acids into the cell be cute
because you could have insulin
resistance right but what caused this
problem in the first is you had you had
too much insulin and then now of a
sudden your body is rejecting it and so
now you're stuck with you can't absorb
insulin yet you have too much okay it's
kind of a weird situation so in an
insulin resistant cell you really are
kind of like your cells are starving for
protein amino acids and fuel so so
here's some symptoms with to know that
you have this number one you can't lose
weight number two you have a bell
at number three a brain fog fatigue if
you skip a meal you get very irritable
you can't go a long time without eating
when you're eating you're not satisfied
when you're eating you get tired right
after you're eating these are just
common symptoms it's kind of a
pre-diabetic State so what happens is
you get this signal sent back to the
pancreas that makes insulin and telling
the pancreas hey we don't have an event
Celyn here so go ahead and pump out more
more insulin because it's being blocked
so now the pancreas thinks that doesn't
have enough so it's driving more and
more insulin to force the nutrition into
the cell so you end up with a real bad
situation because all that excess
insulin creates other issues so here we
end up with a body that doesn't have
amino acids and you get flabby skin and
aging and all sorts of issues with
diabetes yet on the other side all this
excess insulin is creating belly fat but
also a lot of cognitive problems it will
create something called an amyloid or
amyloid fibril with what does that
mean it's amyloids are sticky protein
structures in the brain that are nearly
always found in Alzheimer's Parkinson's
dementia even it's kind of like a
diabetes type 3 it's also found in
strokes I'm going to put some links down
there so here's my thought obviously you
want to increase your longevity of your
memory your brain you don't want to get
Alzheimer's well you want to fix this
insulin resistant problem because
amyloids come from high levels of
insulin and that gets stuck in the brain
and last thing you want to do is end up
with a stroke so they talk about clogged
arteries right well but they don't talk
about amyloids being clogging the
arteries to talk about cholesterol
well amyloid is a protein well so is so
is the cholesterol - it's a high-density
lipoprotein but that's a whole other
lecture but the point is that you may
find that you're getting brain fog and
memory problems and you know going into
the whole Alzheimer's thing realize that
you want to
fix this situation so that way the brain
can start absorbing the fuel it needs
and the protein it means your your
muscles can come back the skin can start
becoming tone so let's just talk about
what that means as far as what you have
to do in your diet number one obviously
you have to get the sugars out okay and
you may already know that refined sugars
breads pasta cereal crackers things like
that secondly you need to get the
alcohol out of your system out of your
diet completely right now because that's
going to create a problem
next one never ever ever ever combine
protein with sugar okay because that
could be even like like the breads with
the bun and the pastries and all that
stuff when you add sugar to protein you
dramatically exaggerate the insulin I
mean like goes way up in fact if you
should add sugar to anything it's
actually even worse you better off
eating sugar alone then you would
combining it so we don't want to add the
sugar even if you add sugar and fat you
accentuate insulin so we don't want to
do that okay snacking will also create
this problem so you don't want to snack
between meals eating fat with the meal
is not going to be a problem because it
allows you to go longer so fat is not
the cause of insulin resistance despite
what some people might tell you
sometimes they'll be do experiments on
rats using corn oil or stone soy oil so
it's it's very very cloudy as far as the
research on that but I found that you
can easily do fats and if you're
concerned just stick with coconut oil
peanuts and things like that but we want
that fat with the meal so you can go
longer without eating so you want two to
three meals a day okay so that's a
really important thing you want the
greens in there you want to avoid the
foods that trigger insulin
okay that's excessive protein combining
protein with sugar sugar itself and
snacking those are the culprits right
there a couple of things let's say you
drink coffee right and you drink a lot
of coffee all that caffeine is going to
trigger more insulin as well so if
you're going to drink coffee
keep it a very small amount only in the
morning and then that's it for the day
okay so so getting your skin back is not
about eating more protein it's about
finding out what's underneath it is it a
stress State is it cortisol is it that
you have no activity like you're not
exercising I mean that could be a
situation because you need to work the
body or is that this insulin resistance
thing which is actually very very common
okay so I just want to enlighten you on
this definitely put your comments below
and I have  a link down there of a quiz that you
can take too so if you have a situation
and you want to find out what's
underneath it fill out the quiz and actually
we'll send you a report that kind of tells
us what's wrong with your body as far as
the root cause okay thanks for watching
I'll see you the next video